[Music]
Wow tampon advocacy news submitted by
aunt Irma seventh graders baked tampon
shaped cookies to demand free minstrel
products at school we think that I guess
they well kids seventh grade seventh
graders big tampon shaped cookies to
demand free mints for products this nice
way to demand for free tampons because I
mean I guess that's around the time that
everyone kind of needs them so and put
the principal apparently at this at this
school says that I said that the male
principal said no because they would and
I quote abused the privilege which my
[ __ ] vagina man it's every [ __ ]
month I don't know that I would call it
a privilege and I don't know that anyone
would abused it like who is yeah it was
like oh the abuse would be they would
grab multiples at a time well again yeah
I did what would they do with it - you
put it in their [ __ ] vagina yeah like
I feel like I'm trying to imagine like
what world easier just like majalis is
crafty seventh graders so many systems
that you can put in place uh you do see
an ID check out like a few months set of
[ __ ] Kaplan yeah that would work
great things you can do
[ __ ] what is you just went with a
heart no instead my heart no with a dumb
reason like if you had a good reason
like hey report yeah sure yes principal
sexist I mean me because he's a male
that's very ignorant what am I to the
vagina coming from it generally male
cast of it but yeah you wanna goes want
to see what the cookies look like yes
damn right I do
all right so I'm not gonna try and load
this picture come with blood yeah yeah
yes or not use okay here we go here we
go they baked it wrong it could look
like sperm oh you know yeah you're right
you're not far off there yeah
interesting is it look like jelly it
looks like a jelly sandwich yeah a
little bit I don't know that that's how
a tampon necessarily yeah I've seen what
a tampon looks like you know what do you
think the string is edible they should
give away free tampons cuz these girls
don't know what to hey and who is
assuming who's to assume it's all girls
making these cookies what if they're you
know other other individuals in their
title said girls right students you're
my building the Blake's seventh grade
students seventh graders baked ham Pond
shaped cookies to demand free menstrual
products at school how dare you assume
that it's only female of course middle
school students then the boys would
definitely be abusing that privilege I
hope so
so Twitter is going in on us obviously
cuz Twitter you know do your thing
[ __ ] Twitter did its thing twinners
on ur comments are Phi's fall was like
privilege is never knowing what it's
like to be caught in public without a
tampon when you need one fantastic these
girls have really hit the perfect
balance of activism peaceful protest and
my favorite snark which I would agree I
think I don't think it's not gay enough
you don't think it's not you know how
how would you make this our gear like
you're giving like the guys getting
cookies man he's like no campus [ __ ]
but you think they're making it to make
fun of him though yeah yeah but he still
gets a treat I disagree we sit on
something and I can't [ __ ] work with
a box of things I said [ __ ] you Nelson
wasn't something like if you put in like
a flavor I hate it I'd be like [ __ ] now
it's like maybe these are blood you
bring the plate of cookies to give to
everyone and then like it's nothing
didn't want it just be like no you can't
have any I'm gonna tell you five dollars
for these cookies oh boy yes oh yeah
sure
yeah that could work everyone get the
cookie but it's not wait a second what
is this combination of both because like
think about it you make something sweet
and nice so he's like oh you know what
these kids are night and secretly are
you gonna do some biological warfare
yeah it's still very into like felony
crimes potential assault cookie you're
not gonna get anywhere with that
strategy I think this is adorable in the
sense that like it's adorable
under the snarkiness just because
they're they're playing nice they're
being really sweet to the point where
you can't hate on them for really trying
to make a point because I don't think
they're being offensive I don't think
that they're being disruptive I think
that it's a very like you know calm way
to sort of like express their
frustration with the administration and
not in a way that is like oh we're gonna
go break something or something like
that they need to mix more red and black
food coloring yeah for it to be a little
bit more accurate I see
expands a little more than just that so
it's just so haven't ever decided not
don't like actually yeah I actually
think that is I agree you know this
actually is like a very interesting like
case study of like kind of getting
someone to better educate themselves
because of the fact that it's not snarky
to the point where maybe he will feel
attacked yeah which like it still sucks
that you kind of have to educate people
in such a soft way but it's like that I
could see that actually being a very
good way to kind of win him over even if
he doesn't agree or understand with it
if it's like alright you know what
hey Mike like these kids this obviously
matters to them and there's a little bit
of humor in it too
so like I feel like that's one of the
better ways to like kind of and it's
soft PR to where he's still given away
where he can still make himself with
them right right yeah as much as I agree
with this and I'm just playing devil's
advocate in this this suggestion what
what's the financial like I don't know
actually I don't know what the financial
leaned on the school a little bit be
that's a good question and I mean I
think that teachers already have to pay
for their own rid of his Ferrari in the
public school system like especially in
like most normal neighborhoods but you
see a lot of BMWs really ya know not my
school the reason I asked it cuz like
with all the like the sexual education
or like you know human sexuality studies
and whatnot they're handing out free
condoms and free like you know sure you
know other other forms of prevention for
like STDs and pregnancy and things like
that but what's what's that gonna do for
tampons you know that's a good question
I think that it definitely speaks a lot
to like the political climate and how
you know underfunded a lot of education
is nowadays I'm just trace I think that
there is room to like I would I would
definitely love to see more you know
public services offer like schools and
stuff especially because it comes with a
lot of education there too around how to
use it you know why are you where's this
where's this do we know where that what
school
is it's a good question depending on the
state depending where you are maybe they
don't even want to talk about yeah it's
right so even the cookie thing could be
a big deal because it's like oh [ __ ] we
don't even want to like think about the
idea of menstrual cycles yeah right it's
definitely in the US based on how this
is being like the way some people talk
about like menstrual cycles and stuff
it's like just avoid it they're like no
I don't want to talk about any of this
or so Sarah what happens are like young
young females are so scared when like
their first period comes it's like oh my
god like how do you how do you talk
about something I mean I don't know at
least like for all my friends who had
their periods early or you know they
didn't expect their period to come but
they bleed through their underwear it
actually goes through their pants and is
actually pretty embarrassing yeah I can
imagine some of them actually go home so
they end up not going to school and they
just go home in the middle of it so
they're actually missing a part of the
education you know either that if
there's a homey other that's like
willing to sacrifice their sweater for
them to tie around their waist like
that's cool but other than that that's a
really like kind of [ __ ] like choice
choice they're just like go home early
from school or just like Shore know that
you're bleeding everyone I think really
not a good choice for anybody such as
simple solution for something to benefit
women like because because it email
we're saying like the whole like okay
they give out free condoms that's still
because it's part of mail enjoyment like
yes coke protesting like people were
doing on Instagram for a while I was
like a big trend or whatever which you
know makes people uncomfortable as [ __ ]
and then the photos got taken down where
the girls would like bleed through their
clothing through there are no where and
then they would take pictures of it
right and then they would get flagged
get taken down imagine if like hundreds
of middle school girls disappear at
school with a bloody ass pants you know
and I'll be like a more aggressive way
so that would be but it'd be like look
what happens if you don't give a [ __ ]
this is gonna happen this is natural
right it's such a delicate time for
girls that age like to like it's just
it's just so embarrassing the fact that
they're so opinionated right now and
like expressing that didn't like the
form of like a cookie you know and in
our bathrooms
I do remember they have like tampon and
pad dispensers but you would have to pay
that's why the boys need us band
together
they're the ones that come to school
soak their pants and blood everywhere
goobers that makes me vomit it tasted by
because yeah yeah also like just you
look historically and stuff like that
when it does come to like women
protesters like that like there's a good
chance they're gonna they're gonna be
the ones punished as opposed to change
actually being enacted yeah so the guys
can get punished for a bit like this is
a fashion statement [ __ ] do you figure
out where it was no there's no thing
here I could probably dig a little bit
more of the internet it's terrible
you're so I don't link to the in the
description box below and show you where
that is another thing that I want to
bring up though because the marketing
side is like oh there's an opportunity
here what if like you could have a like
company sponsor this kind of thing
because I think that that talking from a
business
I hate I hate brand loyalty to this
particular situation for like cigarettes
did this really well like you get kids
using your product and brand recognition
of what product you're using and then
that will continue into like later
stages having okay right right now with
babes right yeah exactly yeah oh yeah
yes you're you're identifying with one
particular product or brand so I think
that there's an opportunity here for
everybody to win it's good PR for them
exactly so but it's a matter of like
really getting those programs into
schools and stuff and I think in a lot
of states that's not necessarily the
political climate of the voters and how
they want their money being spent even
though I think we can all agree here
that's definitely something that should
be looked into more just for public
health because if everyone's healthy
it's a better society everybody's
happier not as many people are
embarrassed and repressed and hurt you
know even if they're you know getting
sick and stuff like that because you die
if you know you're not taking care of it
properly so do you think um of this
protest um that's a good question I
don't think so I think that there's a
lot of
on no comment now what the
administration is saying but I think
that it's you know based on what it's
gotten on Twitter I mean people are
noticing what it is and stuff agreeing
like awareness to it if you want to
count that as a change or whatever bring
up discussion that's always good because
like obviously we haven't gone through
so like Julia what what for you like
early what is it kind of like like
dealing with I guess like a lot of the
different like growth things that like
females go through in school like your
personal experience I don't know it was
it was a weird feeling to feel like
something is coming out of you without
you having any control of it whatsoever
it's not like I can just hold it and be
like you [ __ ] stay in there some
politicians think that you know that was
like just love it you just hold it in
like it was pee you know thousands of
people some people probably waiting
where their resources already like kind
of in play in the school system to help
education what happened or was it like
when those things were at best you have
to opt in I don't know like in fifth
grade
they just made you sit in this like room
I remember them and they play you a tape
oh I think the boys definitely I learn
about it like equally as much yeah being
a politician who thinks UPL blood cuz
there's a lot of people nowadays
sometimes you do very like we're did I
should check that people nowadays that
are still guys that I still like really
weirded out and uneducated on periods
and how they worked like or you'd be
investing right now and like just as an
excuse to blame a woman for something
yeah so like they don't really tell you
exactly what you're gonna go through
when you bleed or like oh you need to
wear a pad when you're bleeding or you
knew where at em probably like they
never said anything it's like oh you're
just gonna bleed out once a month
between five to seven days and and this
is basically the egg releasing out of
you I'm like okay cool go down the
technical the costume but being like we
have a third hole and all the boys are
like weird
and it wasn't till like last year the
year before that all of us guys found
out there's a fourth hole
oh yeah the two holes in the vagina how
they pee out of a different hole oh
that's that's that's what he's
commenting no good there's a third hole
but there's another hook the other hole
that you're thinking of
wait cuz you just look at my mind if
this is real Devon what the number is
girls you go through space
no there's two holes there's two holes
down yeah two plus one equals three no
this is the mouthful there's a bone in
this you got the hero you hold on II
hold it's crazy and all right here
[Music]